[音楽]
すべての悲劇には 6 つの部分があります。 プロット
キャラクター ディクション 思考 スペクタクルと
これらの要素の歌 プロットは
悲劇と模倣にとって最も重要です。
人間のことではなく、行為と人生の模倣であり、
人生は行為で構成され、その
終わりは様式です 平等ではなく行動
7年前、まだ
小説家になろうとしていたとき、
授業を受ける前にアーロン・ソーキンのライティングに関するマスタークラスを受講しました。
エッセイ集を自費出版し、その多くが最終的に
私の最初のYouTubeビデオになりました。
短い小説ですが、
これまで書いてきたものはどれもスケールが非常に小さいものでした
が、ある日、
もっと壮大で説得力のある物語になるかもしれないというアイデアを思いつきましたが、その
アイデアを無駄にしたくありませんでした。
過去に何度もそうしてきたように、自分を隅に追いやるのが
マスタークラスです。
アーロン・ソーキンがこのクラスで強調していることの一つは、
このアリストテレス詩学を読むことの重要性です。
私は日本語を専攻していたので、この本を読んだことがありませんでした。
大学に通っていて、高校時代は演劇少年ではなかったのは
良い言い訳ではないと分かっているので、
これを読み物リストに追加し、
途中でストーリーのメモやアイデアを書き留めながら授業を進めましたが、
その後人生が起こりました。 妻が
妊娠しました。これは私がまだ
Apu で働いていて、
学生募集で月に 2,000 ドルほど稼いでいた頃ですが、
クリエイティブな活動の場であり、将来の収入源となる可能性もあるため、最近始めた YouTube チャンネルも開設した頃でした。
日本語学習 Reddit で私のビデオの 1 つを誰かがシェアしてくれて、ようやく注目を集め始めました。
そこで何人かの人が私に
パトロンを作るよう勧めてくれたので、パトロンを作りました。私は
執筆願望を横に置き、
パトロンを作ることにしました。 日本語の高低
アクセントについて、実際に大学で勉強しました。
もちろん
妻が妊娠中だったので、それを提供しなければならないという大きなプレッシャーを感じていましたが、それに加えて、彼女が
過去3年間働いていたホテルが隣町にありました。
この大地震で破壊されたばかりで、
翌月にはさらなる変化がもたらされました
パトレオンから初めての小切手を受け取りましたが、それは
素晴らしかったですが、その後、
妻が1人ではなく2
人の双子の娘を妊娠していることも知りました 私のApuの
給料は知っていました 4人家族の生活費は決して払えないだろう
が、
YouTubeとパトレオンの両方のプラットフォームの可能性にも気づき始め、
自分が作っているものに誇りを感じるようになったので、
このことやストーリーテリングへの願望は
脇に置いて、その方向に傾いた。  - YouTube グラインドと呼ばれ、
数か月後に子供たちが生まれるまでにそれが報われました。私の
YouTube と有料
パトロンの収入を合わせた収入が Apu の給料よりも大きく、ほんの
少しの
貯蓄と将来への希望が得られたので、
Apu を辞めました。  YouTube と父親になることに傾倒しました
私は
何年もの間、
子供たちが
昼寝をしている間、または
時折映画を見ている間、おむつ交換の合間に YouTube 動画の台本を書き、撮影しました。大変ではありましたが、
とてもやりがいもありました。自分はかなり良い人間になれたように感じました
お父さん、そして私は
小説を書く創作活動をしていませんでしたし、まだこれを読んでいません
でしたが、
日本での生活や
日本語の学習についてのジョークを語る別の形の創作活動で生計を立てていました。これがその
グルーヴです。
YouTube のサブスク数は増え続けることに落ち着いたが、
ストーリーテリングへの願望は徐々に消えていった
が、ある日すべてが変わった
[音楽]
エッジ・ランナーズが大量のレンガのように私を襲った、それは
私が必要としていた警鐘だった とても力強い、
超絶良いストーリーテリングがどのようにできるか、
私はまだ泣かずに
あなたの家に泊まりたいのミュージックビデオを乗り越えることができません私は自分の
人生を完全に見直しました私の目標は何で、
それらを達成するために何をする必要があるかを考えました大好きです 日本での生活と日本語についてのビデオを作成しており、
それは
私が無限に続けるつもりですが、エッジランナーを見て、少なくともストーリーテリングでの創造的な執筆にも従事しようと努めることは不可能になりました。
私はそれをやめて、
特にストーリーテリングやその
形式の創造的な文章に関連することをするために毎朝早起きし始めました、そして
私が最初にやったことは、
アーロン・ソーキンのクラスをもう一度受けて、
そこからジェームズ・キャメロンとデビッド・マンモスをやりました。  『
ザ・ダファー・ブラザーズ』 私は
ようやくこの本
と他の数冊の本を読むことができましたが、より
重要なのは、
50年以上経ってようやく再び執筆することになり、その最中、一連の
信じられないような偶然が重なって、
実際にその作者に出会ったのです。 エッジ・ランナーズ・ラファリヤキのメンバーで、結局
彼と一日を過ごし、このチャンネルで彼にインタビューすることになったのですが、
これらすべてが私を彼のことと
知りました。
私がオリジナルの 2 つのストーリーのどちらについても話せるようになるには、まだ時間がかかります。 創作しようとしていたんだけど、
最近、
別の
執筆プロジェクトに携わることができて光栄だったんだ。それは、ノーネーム・
ラファルの新しいオリジナル作品で、
彼が書いて、素晴らしいマシーン・ガルマンがイラストを描いたものだから、
私はノーネーム・アンド・ラファルの数人の編集者の一人を務めたんだ。
この作品が公開されたので、まず人々にこの作品を読みに行くことを勧めたいと思いましたが、
この機会に、原作漫画の舞台裏での作業がどのようなものであったかについても話したいと思いました。
漫画はどのように作られ、どこから始めますか? まあ、
ラファルもほとんどと同じように、もし
人々が名前の意味に基づいて力を持っていたらどうなるかというアイデアを説明する一文という前提から始めて、
そこから
世界についてもう少し詳しく説明していきました。『ノーネーム』は、を舞台にしたダークアクションミステリーです。
超自然的な力は、政府によって全員に
与えられた人の名前によってもたらされると考えられる北欧。
オオカミと戦う男。コンパニオンと
ウェアベアの少女。
政府が運営する命名機関のために子供の行方不明事件を調査する。
次に、その概要が 9 ページの Google ドキュメントであった。
設定とそのルールを簡潔に説明 1
ページ
ストーリー 別のページと
コンセプト アートを伴うメインキャラクター
説明文は約半ページ、
コモンによる複数ページのコンセプト アート 今、
これは私にとって機会だったので、たくさん質問しました
たとえば、研究を通じて得た知識の一部を試してみる、または秋になると、これが
あなたの最初のオリジナル IP になります。これを 4 つの象限のどれに
最も多く売り込む予定ですか。
主人公たちがこの概要で望んでいることははっきりとわかりますが、
できることはあります。 あなたは、
転落後に私の質問に答えた後、彼らの必要性についてもう少し詳しく
教えてくれました。その後、彼は私や彼
のより有能な友人数人に
フィードバックを
求めました。彼は、登場人物たちが試みる物語の設定についてどう思いますか、具体的に教えてください。
私が情報に基づいたフィードバックを提供できるかどうかはわかりません
でしたが、ラファルは私がフィードバックできると思ったようでした。
日本の銀行のビデオが冗談を言っているからかもしれません。
なぜ彼が作家の部屋
での彼の以前の仕事に基づいて質問したのか理解できます。
理解して頭を包み込むのは非常に難しいです 見落としそうな点について、
自分の仕事を調べ、
外部の目を導入することで、素人の目でも、
この種の間違いをすぐに特定することができます。
自分だけでは気づくのに数か月とは言わずとも数週間かかるであろうものを、 これは
多くの分野に当てはまります。
素晴らしい料理を味わうために優れた料理人である必要はありませんし、
2人のバスケットボール選手のうちどちらがドリブルが上手かを見分けるのにダンクができる必要もありません。
概要についてはあまり多くのフィードバックはありません
が、最初の第一印象は、ああ、
この人がエッジ ランナーズを作った人だということ
でした。しかし、
ラファールがこれらすべての本が推奨していることを正確に実行して
物語を終わらせてくれたことはとても心強かったです
一行の会話を書く前に、複数の解像度で
これが言いたいのは、
彼にはログ行があり、
読者を惹きつける一文があり、その後、
その設定を説明する単一の段落があり、その上に
実際のストーリーのあらすじを再度説明します。
ストーリーは複数のレベルで終了しています。
文レベル、段落レベル、
そして単一ページ レベルです。
これを実行したいと考えています。 ストーリーがどこへ向かうのかを正確に
知る前に会話を書くのは避けたいです。 実際には
ストーリーには必要のない素晴らしい会話やクールなシーンをたくさん書いてしまうことになりませんか。そして、
私がこの記事で何度もやったように、それらを捨てるには少し誇りを持ちすぎるでしょう。
過去とそこで ラファルは、最初の
脚本に別の 36 ページの Google ドキュメントを送りました。
これは、映画の脚本のように、特定の場所でのアクションや会話でストーリーを肉付けしましたが、そこには
ゴブリンの追加のコンセプト アートも
混ぜられていましたが、ラファルは再び私に依頼しました。
フィードバックをいただいて、それを読んでみたのですが、今回
は実際に、対話について
コメントできるかもしれないことがいくつかあると思いました。
対話は決して得意ではありませんが、コメントできるように努めてきました。
YouTube には
少なくとも特定のスタイルを開発するのに十分な期間があり
、その意味で編集プロセスの
この部分では少なくとも何かを活用することができ
ました。
ラファルが書いた行を読んで、
これは素晴らしいと言えるでしょう
このように書いていますが、どう思いますか。
たとえば、最初の草稿の 1 つで、
名前の権力と名前のゲーム
パワー虐待者が
対話自体の中でまさにそのように言及されていることに気づき、
そこに導入する機会があるかもしれないと思いました
それぞれのユニバース固有のスラングは、エッジランナーの
クロムとサイバーサイコという用語をご存知のようなものです。いわば
ユニバースの語彙を拡張すると、冗長性が
削減されるだけでなく、
内容が少し肉付けされると思いました。ラファルは、
それは良い提案だと思いました
その後、脚本の数行を変更しました。
他にも同様の部分がいくつかありました。この行は素晴らしいです
が、この行を少し後ろに押し込むとさらに強力になるかもしれません。
このキャラクターは妻について話します。
息子はその順序でしたが、
後になってそれを反転させるのは
意図的です 個人的にはプロジェクトの
この特定の段階が最も楽しかったと思います つまり、
語順
と言葉の選択について話しているということです
それについて公には決して話しませんが、私はこのことが大好きです
私がこれまでに書いたすべてのツイートは、たとえ一文の長さであっても、事前に
3 ～ 4 時間かけて編集し修正しました。
私と
他の編集者が彼女の携帯電話で話していると同時に、
ガンマはスクリプトを使用してレイアウトを作成していました。
レイアウトの目的は、
ビジュアル ストーリーが
どのように流れるかを把握することです。パネルは何枚ありますか。
一般的に、
その時点から何が見えるのかを理解することです。いくつかの反復が
行われ、スケッチが描かれます。
これらは次のようになります。
実際のポーズや
パネルの表情などを示す絵コンテ その後、
線画が
完成し、ほぼ完成したキャラクターと背景が
完成します。 最後のステップは、ラファルがずっと修正していた最終的なセリフと VFX を追加することです。
新しい物語が生まれる
ノーネームで仕事をするのは信じられないほど楽しかった
もちろん、実際にラファルと仕事をするのは素晴らしかったけど、つまり、
各編集者がまったく
異なることを取り上げ、その過程で非常に多くのことを学んだということです それから、
ガマサンがこの巨大なテキストのブロックを
この印象的なビジュアル
ストーリーに変換するのを見るのは、これも信じられないほど素晴らしかったです。
創造的なプロセスに加えて、ラファルは物事の
ビジネス面も共有してくれたので、
コスト、契約、マーケティング
戦略など、これは非常に価値がありました
私にはビジネスの洞察力がないので、
でもそれは、ラファルを含む
私のお気に入りのクリエイター全員が
過去に言っていたことを強化するものでもあり、これは
あなたが最もクールなアイデアを持つことができるということでした、つまり、最も機知に富んだ会話の
中で最も巧妙なキャラクターを意味します
が、誰もそうはしません 実際
に市場に持ち込めない限り、
時間と労力を費やさなければならないことはわかりません、
早起きして、
すべての権利を書かなければなりません、それで終わりです、チェックアウトしてください no name
ラファルとガマサンが
一緒に作ったものは次のとおりだと思います
壮観以外の何ものでもないし、
このプロジェクトに小さな役割を果たせたことを本当に光栄に思う。
以下にリンクされているシュー・ア・ショット・マンガ・プラス・プラットフォームで無料で読むことができる。再生回数はちょうど100万回を超えたばかりだ。
新しいコメディービデオは近日公開予定だ。
音楽]
[音楽]
ありがとう